will fit in here at work we will give
verses to talks on Cisco reference
reasons why so yes I will fit in and I I
have two hours to tell you basically the
contents of my one semester course so if
you - so these are these are the topics
I'm going to try to cover if you've seen
all of these before I won't be offended
if you get up and leave
okay so so we'll just start out by by
going over the sort of most basic
statistical problem that we might solve
estimation
okay so to begin with what is a
statistical model it's a it's just a
family of candidate probability
distributions or some data that we
observe
[Applause]
so we'll say we use the notation we can
just say P script P is just a set and we
have a distribution P theta for each
value little theta coming from a
parameter space capital theta so this
notation is of course suggested that
theta is a real number or a real vector
but the in fact we could use the same
notation if capital theta were some huge
infinite dimensional space this isn't
really just doesn't just cover what we
would usually call parametric inference
but we're going to certainly focus on on
those examples so a few simple examples
that we'll talk about so X is a binomial
and theta or here theta is in set zero
one or that the X is normal beta one
where now theta could be any real number
or a sort of more nonparametric example
we could just say let's say x1 this is
getting closer to a sort of realistic
example we might deal with in real life
we have x1 up to xn are iid P y1 up to Y
M say are iid Q and maybe we have no
idea what P and Q are but we might want
to do something like test whether
they're the same thing
or compute an estimator or a confidence
interval for the difference in means
between these two distributions without
having to worry about what parametric
form they take ok so an estimation
an estimation problem we observe data
that that just one draw from one
realization from one of these
distributions and then we have to our
goal is to sort of guess something about
the distribution and then we guess
some s demand just any function of the
data so in in these first two cases G of
theta is probably just theta whereas
here it could be something like the
expectation of Q minus the expectation
of P so an estimate or Delta X is a
function of the data that somebody
intended to be a good guess of G G of
theta so any function of the data is
also called a statistic of course it's
important it can only be a function of
the data and not not the parameter
obviously because we don't get to see
the parameter and so we want to guess as
well as possible so to to start thinking
about how we might come up with a good
estimator
we have to start off by saying well what
would make us happy what what aspect of
a guess would actually make us happy so
the next thing we define is the loss
function
say L of theta D is just a function so
whatever the parameter was and and
whatever we happened to guess for G of
theta the loss function is like minus of
the utility function tells us how
unhappy we are with that outcome is how
badly we do
yes if we make me guess
D and the true parameter was theta so
typical or the say the example you see
hopefully more commonly than any other
would be the squared error loss so here
L of theta D we could define it to be D
well we do guess versus what we were
trying to get quantity squared okay so
that's this is how well we do for a
particular say for any given realization
but we have to design an estimator so
you know when we design an estimator we
don't know yet what the data are going
to be we certainly don't know what the
parameter is but we need we want to come
up with some with an estimator that's
going to do well most of the time it's
gonna give us a good loss most of the
time and so we define the risk function
or the wrist is like the expected loss
function or also called the you know
like minus the expected utility function
risk
now the risk is a function not only of
the parameter but off but now of the
estimate or is how badly we do on
average so it's expectation
data L theta Delta of X and so in so
this we called the squared error loss
and if we were using the squared error
loss then the risk would be exactly the
the mean squared error so that's a good
question no to the risk so the risk is a
function of theta so we're not averaging
over theta okay so I so so I okay in
some corners of the mathematical world
people put the dummy variable the thing
you're integrating over in the subscript
here we don't do that in statistics in
statistics if you're always integrating
over everything in the problem that's
random and frequentist statistics theta
is not is not considered random it could
be in which case we would always
integrate over it but so here when I say
e sub theta I mean the expectation
doesn't have a meaning until I tell you
what theta is expectation with respect
to which measure the measure
corresponding to theta and so that's
what that means
yes and if if there were anything that
we didn't want it to average over then I
would have to say I'm conditioning on it
yeah okay okay so this risk
so this risk is a function not only of
the estimator this is our choice our
choice variable is what estimator we use
but we don't have control over of what
nature chooses is this parameter theta
so let's just do a really simple example
three estimators for the binomial so
suppose that X is binomial and theta and
let's consider three possible estimators
so first let's call Delta zero X this is
the most obvious estimator you would
think of so I have n coin flips each one
has a probability of coming up say two
times let's just take the empirical
fraction of times when X comes up heads
so that's an obvious estimator but is it
a good one is it is it the best one this
is a question so let's consider another
estimator Delta 1 of X and we'll just
say X plus 3 over N and let's make let's
put in a third 1 Delta 2 of X and that's
X plus 3 over n plus 6 so for each of
these we can can okay can people see
this what Oh does the kit the only
camera can only go so low huh okay good
thanks
here if I plot the mean squared error or
okay the risk function against the
parameter theta okay so we know that
Delta 0 of X the expectation is just
theta so that mean squared error is
exactly the variance of Delta 0 and we
know the variance is Theta is well 1
over
variance divided by N squared so it's 1
over n times theta 1 minus theta so we
can just plot that parabola and we have
we always get it exactly right if theta
is 0 or 1 so this is for Delta 0
delta-1 it actually looked like delta0
but exactly it happens to be shifted up
that's not so great
and then for delta ii it's flatter than
Delta one so okay so a couple things
just to point out about these functions
though Delta zero and Delta two are
definitely better than Delta one so we
say Delta one is is inadmissible in the
sense that there there exists another
function that they're just another
estimator that we could have chosen
whose risk function dominates its it
dominates it means that the risk
function is always at least as low we
can find another estimator with a
function with the risk function always
at least as loved and strictly lower at
some point so you would think from the
name and from what the definition is we
would never ever use an inadmissible
estimator that's almost true but it
actually gets more interesting than that
we're not going to go in into that but
it's not quite always true but in this
case we have the right intuition that
this is just a bad estimator but if
we're comparing Delta zero and Delta two
it's not really clear which one is the
better estimator it's right so they just
neither one is uniformly dominating the
other and in fact so you might hope that
we could find a fourth estimator that
uniformly dominates all three on this
board and furthermore dominates every
other estimator so we can sort of see
immediately that there's no hope of that
because consider the estimator where I
Oh
no matter what happens I always guess
theta equals 0.5 I cannot possibly beat
that estimator if theta really is 0.5 so
there is no hope of finding one
estimator that that is you know at least
as good as every other estimator
everywhere so our only hope is to try to
come up with a way to compare risk
functions that don't uniformly dominate
each other badly I guess okay if I
wanted to plot them on the computer so
I'm just plotting the mean squared error
let me postpone that a couple boards
down the road to when I talk about the
bias-variance tradeoff but but well okay
so well we we know the first two moments
of X and so we can compute the mean
square that would be if the shorter yeah
yeah we know the first two moments of X
as functions of theta and so
okay so so we're never gonna we're never
gonna hope to find one estimator to rule
them all so so what can we how can we
actually proceed here it's not very
satisfactory to just throw off our hands
and say you might as well choose the one
that always chooses theta to be one half
so a couple so there are a few different
strategies to resolve this and really
you kind of have to bring sort of
knowledge about the problem or your more
sort of scientific motivations into the
problem to to really choose between
these in any particular case but some
typical strategies to resolve this
ambiguity
so first would be summarize the risk
function as a scaler
and the two most common ways of doing
that would be worst-case risk so well
I'll do average case risk first an
average case risk and worst case risk so
an average case risk we will we just
take the average of the risk function
but now the question is average with
respect to what way of averaging over
the parameters based average with
respect to what measure and that measure
we call a prior distribution so we have
some measure lambda on the parameter
space notice you don't have to bring in
any kind of epistemological trappings
about sort of having a subjective belief
about the data we can just say we're
doing average case risk here so we have
some some distribution on the parameter
space capital theta and then we would
try to minimize over our choices of
estimator we find the estimator that
minimizes now the integral over the
parameter space
averaging with respect to to that
distribution so the simplest one to take
there would be just uniform distribution
from zero to one if we did that I think
we would get X plus one over n plus two
and that would be the best estimator in
that sense so this is this is called
Bayes risk
this risk is called the bathe risk for
the prior lambda and the actual
estimator that minimizes here is the the
Bayes estimator so I'll talk in a bit
more depth about Bayes in a moment but
let's move on so the second way to
summarize would be worst-case risk
best-case risk is not really in play
because we would choose the one you
choose on deterministic estimator but
worst-case risk is pretty reasonable so
then we can try to minimize over Delta
now the supremum over the whole
parameter space of the risk function so
this is called the minimax risk and so
here where we have here we have sort of
a an intuition that nature is is drawing
the is drawing the parameter from some
distribution and then we have to
estimate it here instead we have a more
game theoretic intuition where nature is
going to wait and see what estimator we
choose and then choose the worst
possible parameter to mess us up I set
question I guess bias case you want to
always kind of the same state
the what case risk the variance of the
risk well it's interesting you should
ask so it's not always it's not I don't
know that this is a theorem but in in
many problems the minimax risk the
minimum acts estimator turns out to be a
Bayes estimator and it's a Bayes
estimator for which you have some kind
of Nash equilibrium with nature so
there's some Nash equilibrium choice for
nature to choose the least favorable
that we call it the least favorable
prior and with respect to that prior we
actually get a flat risk function so in
fact you can prove that if you is so
it's actually a very short proof if you
can find a Bayes estimator with a flat
risk function then you know you have the
minimax risk because the only way to
have a minim Act bet of a better minimax
risk for any estimator you would have to
dominate that risk function and no Bayes
estimator can be dominated okay sorry
let me actually these are a few good
theorems that are you can sort of
quickly see in your head any Bayes
estimator is admissible why if I had it
so it's a I have a Bayes estimator if
you tell me that you've got another
estimator with a better with that whose
risk is strictly dominating the Bayes
estimator well then the Bayes estimator
can't actually have the best average
case risk right and in particular if I
can find a Bayes estimator with a flat
risk function so because it's a Bayes
estimator it's admissible and it has a
flat risk function and so there couldn't
be flat
I have a flat risk function here I can't
squeeze in any other risk function
that's always that has a smaller supreme
Mbeki it would have to always be smaller
than this risk function so any Bayes
estimator with a flat risk function
actually is minimized so maybe that's in
partial answer I'm sure that from time
to time other people have come up with
other ways of summarizing the risk
function I mean they're okay I guess
they're it's so called adaptive minimax
rules where you but okay so there I
guess there are more complicated
variants of minimax I'm not that aware
of other ways that people have tried to
yes just to understand on this example
would be the worst case estimator for
the the binomial the minimize risk
estimator for the binomial okay so I
don't know at the top of my head but and
it would depend on n probably but would
depend on n but it would be we would
look for a prior that makes the risk
function flat that's how we would find
them in a max estimator and so it would
be you know there are not that many
priors to choose from in some sense
because oh oh right so among these three
delta2 has the best minimax risk yeah
but there is a one that has a better
minimize risk and it has a flat risk
function to find what that is the you
know there's some math you find the
prior that that makes I don't I don't
think that there's sort of a way to turn
the crank and do the computation and get
the minimax risk but in this picture
there's no
right in this no we're just plotting
risk functions that's right the worse is
okay so the worst-case risk there is no
prior and setting up the problem it
happens it so happens to be the case
that most minim axe estimators are also
base estimators so it's more like a
heuristic that you do to find sure it's
one way so yes yes yes it is in fact in
this in this problem just taking X to be
the estimator is minim X but it's not a
base estimator so minimax estimators
don't always have to be base so okay so
we can summarize the risk is a scalar
and then we get the average case risk or
the worst case risk days and minim ax
and a third a third way that people have
tried to break this ambiguity
is by putting some kind of constraint on
the set of estimators that we can choose
the most common one historically being
to require that the estimator must be
unbiased the second way would be to
constrain the estimator so there might
be some natural property that you think
the estimator should have you might
think it should respect some symmetry of
the problem or or you might just say no
matter what theta is I want to have an
unbiased estimator so an unbiased
estimator so for example consider only
unbiased Delta so unbiased means that
the expectation theta for for every
value of theta in the parameter space
and it turns out that if we erase them
that so there are a lot of problems
where if we only make this requirement
than there actually is one estimator
that is uniformly better than all other
estimators and depending on the problem
people sometimes find this to be a
natural requirement so I think that this
the this requirement of unbiasness
however is somewhat fallen out of
fashion in the last few decades
so now bias is viewed more as something
to be managed than something to be that
you would try to completely eliminate
and that brings me to my next topic
which is the bias variance trade-off
so we can write the MSE of an estimator
the expectation Delta of X minus G of
theta squared so here I'm going to
define use of theta to be the
expectation of Delta of X and okay just
to simplify the notation I'm gonna use
say 2 here instead of G of theta and so
views Musa theta would just be equal to
theta if Delta of X were an unbiased
estimator and so this this leads us to a
very famous decomposition of the mean
squared error where we just add and
subtract
new theta and so what do we get we get a
sum of three terms
start again
okay so we get the sum of three terms
Delta of X minus mu theta squared so
that's the variance plus the expectation
of MU theta minus theta squared and here
we don't need the expectation anymore
because these are just real numbers
minus two times the expectation of
something that has mean 0 times
something that's not random and so this
thing this whole thing goes away and so
what we get is the variance the Delta of
X plus and this is the bias squared
plus the bias squared and so so this is
completely precise if we're taking the
mean squared error to be our risk
function more generally we may be
interested in many other risk functions
other than the mean squared error but we
sort of still used this bias-variance
tradeoff is sort of a metaphor that you
have some estimators that really
intensely regularize the answer so this
one here where this is equivalent to
saying pretend I flipped to the I'm
gonna make up data where I flipped the
coin six times and I got three heads and
essentially it results in a convex
combination between this estimator and
one half so this estimator it has lower
variance because part you know it's only
only it's a convex combination because
between something that's random and
something that's fixed whereas here it's
just the random thing so this one has
lower variance but it has some bias and
in the places where Delta two is losing
it's because the bias wins out in the
places where it's winning it's because
the variance wins out and so more
generally we sort of think that for all
kinds of in all kinds of statistical
problems that we approach we very much
think in terms of bias variance
trade-off
well it depends on what you start from
if you start from a bad enough estimator
he certainly could but if you have an
admissible estimator then you couldn't
uniformly improve so next I'm going to
talk a little bit more about about Bayes
risk so here we've sort of introduced
Bayes risk the Bayes risk and and
Bayesian Bayes estimators from a
completely frequentist motivation but
more generally you know bait in Bayes
Bayesian inference we might actually
sort of start off and interpret this
capital lambda as an actual sort of
prior belief over what the value of
theta might be and in that case there's
actually a lot less that we need to say
so all the things that we've been saying
here about trade-offs and you know
properties of different estimators they
become sort of moot so in Bayes in
Bayesian inference everything is in some
sense a lot more simple
so we actually sort of believe
believe capital lambda as a real prior
distribution than things simplify
considerably so so say
okay to say we have some prior density
lambda of theta and D theta of X is the
density of the the distribution in our
model corresponding to theta so now
we're sort of thinking of the parameter
and and the data is being random so now
if if it's really true that theta is
coming randomly from lambda and X given
theta is being drawn from from P theta
conditionally then we actually can say
exactly what then theta given X you can
just write down what the what the
distribution is let's write V of theta
given X and it's just proportional to
the prior
time's the likelihood so this is the
posterior distribution mysterio density
in this case and it's a complete so so
it sort of describes if if this was our
belief about the data before about the
parameter before seeing the data and
then we see this data then this
posterior density describes our belief
state about what the parameter should be
after seeing the data and it's and we
don't really need to talk that much
about estimators or hypothesis testing
or confidence intervals because the
posterior is just a complete description
of everything that we might believe
about the data so you might want to
summarize it in some way for some reason
and the posterior it sort of combines
the prior let's say we have the prior
and the likelihood lambda P theta of X
and then they sort of get combined into
something that hopefully looks a lot
more narrow so now we have a lot more
information
about the distribution and so for
example if if we if we do somehow if we
do for whatever reason care about coming
up with an estimator it has the smallest
mean squared error then it's very clear
how to do it
we just take the posterior mean so the
Bayes estimator
or the mean squared error it's just the
posterior mean so to minimize so we want
to minimize e now lambda is the
everything well we first can condition
on X
so we can just conditioned on X and so
now once we're looking at this internal
conditional expectation well now after
we've conditioned on X X is just fixed
yeah X is just fixed and so we're going
to draw some G of theta from the known
posterior distribution of theta given X
and we want to choose a number Delta of
X that's going to be as close as as
possible to it in in X in squared
squared distance and it's not hard to
show that the way that that you minimize
this function is to choose so this
number we get to choose after seeing X
we choose this number to be the mean of
the distribution of this number it's not
hard to show and so very similar
arguments give Bayes estimators for
really any other loss that you would
want you wait and see the data now once
you've seen the data now the you know
theta is going to come from some
distribution and so you can just compute
exactly what the the conditional loss is
the conditional expectation of the loss
is going to be for any choice of your
estimator and you pick the one with the
smallest
sorry VIN so blam that in both cases
there yeah they both depend on lambda
yeah and it is the posterior lambda over
on the right there no this is the major
lambda from which theta is marginally
drawing posterior lambda in the ground
posterior oh sorry no I didn't mean that
to be labeling lambda Thanks
right so okay so so again the read the
only reason I'm putting this in
subscript is because it's you know what
this expectation it depends on what the
prior is so now the prior is the thing
that's fixed it drives what we
integrated whether we integrate with
respect to okay so the the only question
that okay so so Bayes infrared Bayesian
inference it sounds great and generally
we there are very strong reasons to want
to do it so the question is why don't we
always do it that way so first of all
computationally as I'm sure many of you
know computationally this we can sort of
run into more problems than might look
evident particular this sort of
proportional symbol is doing a lot of
work here and the devil can kind of be
in the computational details for a lot
of Bayes methods but I would say there
are there are bigger issues and in in
sort of a lot of statistical and a lot
of scientific applications the real
question that we might snag ourselves on
is just where are we going to get it
prior so the so there's the question is
sort of where where is the prior going
to come from so there are a few
different possible answers to this
question so first it could sort of come
from direct prior experience so maybe we
actually have a lot of parallel
instances of a similar problem to solve
in that case we could just sort of
estimate the prior from all of the other
instances this is usually called
empirical Bayes this is essentially
uncontroversial another possibility
however would be that you somehow that
really the prior just sort of reflects
your subjective beliefs so you just
search inside of yourself and you ask
yourself what is the prior you don't
need to get it from anywhere it just
comes from inside of you it just
reflects your your own
so in a scientific paper if you if you
publish the posterior then part of what
you're publishing I suppose is what your
opinion is after seeing the data and
people sort of find this to be less
objective so they find some problem with
that and I would say maybe some people
would have a philosophical problem with
that but even if you don't have a
philosophical problem with that it
becomes very difficult to express what
your subjective opinion is over an
extremely high dimensional parameter so
here we've been talking about the
binomial or the normal distribution but
I also mentioned remember we have we
could have a problem like x1 up to xn
are iid P y1 up to Y M are iid Q so this
would be a typical example in statistics
where there actually is a lot that we
can do with this problem just leaving P
and Q is being completely unknown from a
frequentist perspective from a Bayesian
perspective before we even get going we
have to somehow specify what our Joint
Distribution is over these two let's say
two distributions over the real numbers
this is a very hard thing to express
what is your opinion that P has a little
wiggle here also whether Q has a little
wiggle over here and moreover what's the
joint probability of those two things
together it's not really plausible that
you could even elicit what your opinion
is let alone have a reasonable opinion
okay so that's enough rambling about
Friar's it's any questions on this I'm
about to move on to hypothesis testing
from estimation yes G's function
the distribution G of theta is it so
important do you mean why isn't Delta of
X Brandon given the data okay so why
don't we have why couldn't we choose a
randomized estimator we could so there
might be some contexts where you would
consider that for a lot of risk
functions so generally for a convex risk
function you would make your loss worse
you would make your risk worse by
randomizing so so so for most risk
functions that we would consider that we
usually consider it wouldn't really help
but more generally it might help I
suppose they could be computational an
investment the opthamology if it now
might be hard to guess with from
us-based typical one might be the Delta
effects the amine our Delta X is our
guess who C weeks and then
yes maybe we'll do this later like
maximum like do estimated Alissa's means
there okay so okay so these are all very
sort of finite sample ways of looking at
the world the maximum likelihood
estimator is a great all-purpose
estimator that I'll get to later we
won't have time to talk about sort of
the optimality properties of the maximum
likelihood estimator but the maximum
likelihood estimator in nice asymptotic
regimes basically does as well as you
could hope for asymptotically and it's
very easy to just say what you're doing
so there is a lot there can be a lot
less ambiguity in in the nicest
asymptotic regimes but we spend less
time studying the nicest asymptotic
regimes yes what does MSE mean on this
board mean squared error it's a mere is
the basis so so if we if our risk
function is the mean squared error then
we can't uniformly minimize mean squared
error so we said a strategy is we're
going to do take the Bayes track so
we're going to use a particular prior oh
so lambda is the prior distribution
that's what you're integrating against
for this Bayes estimator yeah maybe I
should have said the babies estimator
for the squared error loss you do that
yes yes if we carried out that program
for the prior lambda here
yes so in the InDesign so we are not
it's why not taking the Caucasian Oblast
attacks minor suggested in this line or
this oh yeah so I just a right to make
it easier on me cuz gf8 often is beta
and so just to cite in the Droid G as
many times I just dropped the G in this
area yes if their framework to look at
suppose your maker different prior your
random variables are coming from a
certain diet eat or not and you take
some theta that somewhat abashed is sort
of framework where you won't do as bad
so I'm sure there is that would be not
within my area of research expertise oh
sure people so some some people do so
here we we're sort of mixing
philosophies not necessarily in a bad
way but from the Bayesian philosophy if
you sort of have a oh actually not
really okay so you're you're talking
about from a frequentist perspective
what are the frequentist properties of a
Bayes estimator when the prior is
misspecified and i'm i know that people
have studied this but i i i don't know
that much about direct to you
yes
yes
so the way we would formalize it is
usually we would have some kind of
generally for empirical Bayes you have
some kind of repeated structure in the
problem
so for non-empirical just regular
hierarchical Bayes you can do this too
so you can say so let's say I have some
so that X X i given theta I so the I
have baseball player is batting average
empirical batting average conditional on
it's true batting average let's say is
binomial and I theta I but the but the
baseball players eyath the I of baseball
players true batting average is also
coming from some distribution let's say
not normal and say beta alpha beta but
so this this would be sort of a regular
base setup where the problems would just
separate out if we specified what alpha
and beta are but now that we actually
have many baseball players we have an
opportunity to learn alpha and beta so
we could do this in a completely
Bayesian not empirical Bayesian
framework but just a hierarchical
Bayesian framework to say then also will
say alpha and beta come from some
distribution lambda so maybe we give
then now I had to pass by lamda yeah but
but actually so once I set up this
problem specifying lamda there's sort of
less at stake it's hard to formalize
what that means but practically speaking
there's less at stake in in defining
this as long as we because we have a lot
of we sort of have a lot of repeat
observations potentially letting us nail
down alpha and beta so if you have
really good if you have really good data
on the parameter it doesn't matter that
much what prior you put on it this is
sort of a folk folk theorem or something
right there are there real theorem
versions of that statement but if you
have a lot of data about something then
it doesn't matter that much what prior
you put on it so here we might be able
to learn alpha and beta very well and so
we could just put a very sort of wide
prior on theta so the agnostic prior and
we probably would get pretty good
estimators for okay very pretty good
beta or at this point though if you said
there's so little stake on the prior why
why put a prior on it at all why not
just take these to be numbers that we
should give unknown parameters that we
can estimate that we don't have to worry
about choosing a prior at all and and
there's not that much difference
practically between those two
so this reminds so I only have five
minutes it is not enough time to start
with hypothesis testing but this reminds
me I should have mentioned another way
to come up with priors is a lot of times
what people will do is they'll just
choose a very wide prior so they try to
put a very wide prior say if theta is a
is some real number you could put some
prior that spreads information way
across a huge range of values way more
than you think is actually plausible for
the parameter and the idea behind doing
this is then at that point the prior has
less influence you're you're sort of not
good of your you're not injecting your
opinion into the problem but then you
lose a lot of really nice
interpretations of all the things I said
about Bayes is that all you need to know
is is the posterior well if you chose
the prior just because if you chose the
prior based on some automatic rule
rather than what you actually believed
that the prior isn't what you fully
believed before seeing the data then the
posterior isn't what you believe after
seeing the data so it's so things
conceptually simplify less and we're we
probably have to at that point think of
it more as a frequentist estimator but
it may be a very good frequentist
estimator and so we shouldn't reject it
yes and earlier today so the the max
risk doesn't depend on it
on a prior that's right the integral of
the fifth power of the risk then that
would depend on the prior but Nvidia
would look more like the max rest Oh
that's interesting yeah
okay well I guess that at this point
there's no need for me to insist on
speaking for three more minutes so I'll
see you all after the break
[Applause]